the jurogan experience my own point of
view with all with with thinking that
that you know extravagant is is that i
i think i'm a complete solipsist i think
everything around me is some sort of
holographic
thing that i'm dropped into for the
duration of my life and when i die it
all disappears
really yeah i kind of do think so i
think i think it's um
i also think that there's
there's uh everything that is going to
happen has already happened and there's
a paradox where free will also exists
so i think that i think i have the
ability to go around and act with free
will i don't think that things are
completely deterministic
but i think the free will is informed by
the biological programming we were
talking about before
um but i'm still choosing within a given
set of what i'm allowed to choose from
um but the paradox is also that i think
that by
you know i'm probably on my deathbed if
you collapse time down and look at it as
like a linear you know thing if you just
if you just observe it it's like
neil's death is here his birth is here
these are these other events
theoretically with free will as you move
through that three-dimensional map these
other events should change right each
day with choices you make all of these
other outcomes should move
and somehow i don't think they do i
think that they're kind of locked in
place
and nietzsche speaks about that he calls
it eternal recurrence
and it's like eternal recurrence was
something that i got i got quite
interested in because it felt true to me
uh how so how so felt true
well he says he says that he says that
what what happens is that your life is
sad and all of the events within your
life
not only are set but they will also
recur infinitely through time
so um instead of the idea of
reincarnation it's almost like the idea
of reincarnation into your own life
eternally and so someone else from a
different point of view would be able to
see the this event of like joe rogan's
life
and see you make these choices and then
they would see you begin and make these
choices again and he kind of used it as
a thought experiment where he said
he said that if i if i went to most
people out in the world and i said to
them
that your life is going to repeat
exactly like this forever
he said it was a burden that would be
too heavy for most people to be able to
deal with yeah that their life is
that they don't want to live their life
over the way that they've lived it
enough that it would be literally the
worst burden that they could be given
i've pondered this before and i've heard
this brought up before in fact elio
gracie is a famous brazilian jiu jitsu
guy who
was uh he's the
he's a patriarch of like the greatest
martial arts clan ever yeah he believed
that he believed you will live your life
over and over again until you get it
right
yeah nietzsche is saying that you you
don't get the chance to do it right it's
locked in place it's locked in place
except
exactly the same way forever yeah
but why why would he believe that
because you can ch but if you believe in
free will that's the paradox yeah so if
you believe i think you'll make the same
choices over and over but why but
because you're not learning each time
you go back you're not it's not a
different version of you
it's the same version of you but why
haven't you learned from the past
because you it to us we are the birth
and the death is one event
but if you are having
the same life experience over and over
and over again
what is you
if that's you having the same
is it
new versions of you or is it you no it's
just one it's just you yeah and why
don't you learn
what what
he because from from a from a
three-dimensional standpoint in in that
linear timeline
when you die you that feels like the end
of the play from it from a fourth
dimensional different observational
standpoint you can watch it repeating
but his point was was with free will
inside of that linear timeline you
should live your life in a way that the
that you would want it to go on forever
it was sort of a thought experiment yeah
but what what i was getting at was the
feeling that to me it feels like things
are set in place
and because this comes from the the
solipsistic thing that we were talking
about where
i think that it's it's all in the the
person it's in the observer's eyes
right and by the and i also think time
is an illusion as well so by the time
you get to the end of your life and
you're lying on your deathbed
um
you you all of these events could have
been a dream it could just be a fever
dream you know um
so they they weren't because you free
will exist and you acted on them but
time compresses down to this moment
and and and that's the only thing that's
there is the sort of this present moment
that you're living inside of but it's
being committed to this idea that all
these things are playing out is that
comforting is that why you're willing to
embrace it that way that there's no
getting around this and that this is
what it is no i mean i don't i don't act
like i don't have free will right and i
don't act like things are set in place i
just on a very very
deep subconscious level i feel like they
are
so you feel like fate is real in some
ways
in some ways it is yeah i do think
there's a paradox though i think there's
a definite paradigm you think about that
when you're making films do you think
you think like
as because
the the creative process of writing and
then i'm sure i've never edited a film
but i would imagine editing and filming
it and choosing the angles
you're
visualizing this creation and you're
putting it together and then ultimately
you get a final product and yeah that's
what people do it's similar to people's
lives i mean you could say right
the choices that you're making because
there's infinite possible there's
infinite possible outcomes right and
you're collapsing that down you're
collapsing the wave the wave function
into one
outcome and
so
that's what i think is happening i think
that we're given infinite numbers of
options and we have the ability to act
on on those we choose a path and in in
the action of choosing we collapse all
possibility to one outcome and the tree
is crushed down watch the entire episode
for free only on spotify